but it's not just women like the
questions
it's more like how women can be sexist
and black and black people can be racist
in in this i think that's a better
equivalent what do you say
so i think it's a better equivalence is
like how women can be
allowed to be sexist the same way black
people allow to be racist
that's another conversation no no that
because that's a different conversation
no the question is why is it okay for
women to be sexist and not racist
because it's it's just
common right it's so it's so like
misandry is so common i hear it every
day but nobody bats an eye
but if but if we switched it to race
they would so is it sexist then the
example you gave of
basically telling a woman you know a man
is different from you you should have
some level of genuine fear like you
can't just walk into a man's house that
you don't know off nowhere and think
he's just another girl you can't treat a
man like a woman right but i'm saying
you shouldn't walk into anyone's house
you don't know
i'm not i'm not walking into wales
houses
why are you is this a common
guys did your problem have to tell you
that
no some girls literally felt like i
personally have seen some girls feel too
comfortable around men and i'm just like
hoes
[Music]
i don't like to use that word
jezebels
there you go
yeah some girls just feel very confident
and i feel like it just comes from a
lack of or even hitting a man it comes
from a lack of fear of that man because
like you have no
fear within you that knows that oh he's
different if he slaps me once i could
die like you literally don't have that
in you and i think that i wouldn't say
teaching someone to
in quote unquote have this kind of fear
i'm not saying be afraid like never talk
to men again but have a fear of
genuinely he can take my life if he
wanted to
um
i don't think that's sexist it's common
sense it's not even of his fear
it's common sense
a man has testosterone testosterone
makes you strong and if someone has more
testosterone than you then
they're going to be stronger than you
you shouldn't put yourself in that
situation
but the point is they're
they're discriminating against a whole
group
i think they are racist towards some
races though women right and it's a very
acceptable like with indian men you know
yeah it's become a joke now how men
slide into your dms yeah but that's not
that's sexual preference
do you think do you think like you could
say the same thing with short guys it is
it is i think it is i agree with you but
for society it's it's really saying you
must sleep with them
i agree with you i agree with you but
now with indian men it's become a joke
like you keep hearing how indian men
slide into yeah yeah dms and they make
fun of them and it's it is sort of okay
but i think pearl your point is on a
higher level i think and i think it's
about the the double standard that we
have in society
that
why is it okay to be racist
when it's okay to be
misandrist and i think you mentioned it
earlier you answered your own question
where
you said that men are expendable
we've been living through decades
of men being
told and women being told
that men should be disrespected in the
home men should be
their value is really nothing other than
the check
and the seed
and
men have been portrayed as bumbling
idiots
when
actually
what men do is very productive to
society and required and necessary not
just for young boys but also for girls
you know what i've noticed if you watch
ads on tv these days the man is always
the dumbass and the woman comes to the
rescue
fixing whatever it is have you noticed
that
70 to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions are made by women so they're
always marketing to women i have an
accident i have a question for you pro
because i don't know if anybody else
notices that you may know it but
are the stats the same because nowadays
we have um
another sector of sexuality trans men
and trans women are the stats the same
if a
woman
is
know if a man is now with a trans woman
or a vice versa what those stats be the
same i i don't know okay i wasn't
interested it's probably too soon
because to me it's just like they're
still a dude you can dress like a dude
that doesn't make you
you call them [ __ ] you know it was
just accepted that there would be one
dude among a group that liked to dress
in women's clothes why is it okay to be
trans
someone asked us in the chat why is it
okay to like change your sex but you
can't change your race
i've
i think she should be allowed like she
actually helped black people
i think change your race if you if you
want to change your race like
do you like it actually a free world
it's not that
if i really wanted to be black yeah i
could just i could just go go tanning
that's blackface and yeah and yeah
and
just
get i don't know and dress
i think the idea is no no no no i could
dress i could dress in african clothes
no
i i'm so surprised that you two just
said that this lady
let me know
specifically
she worked to help black people okay
okay let's see let's see
okay let's let's say let's say
if i the next two years i i start an
orphanage in africa
i'm just asking i'm just asking then i
come back
would that win me would i could i change
my race the way i i i trust no no i just
need a yes or no
of course not no
i don't actually agree with racial
daughters or doing that what i'm saying
okay
she said
so you're asking me if it's okay for you
to change your race yeah i think you can
change your race in your own little self
but don't expect me to call you black or
give you a pass to say the n word would
you just say okay no no no i said i said
yeah do if you want to identify as a god
damn table be a table for all i care
just don't force me to then put my cop
on you and pretend you're a table
i'm not going to see you
see here the thing this is the thing
right this is this is where it starts
we start by allowing people to do it in
their own and then those people get
entitled in the i know
yeah no that's true you're right it's a
slippery slope because i mean if we told
caitlyn frickin jenner that she couldn't
have the female courage award like seven
years ago where would we be today she's
she's the world's greatest yeah thank
you very much
yes
and then we now we got that freaking
that dude swimming in the girls division
and taking our titles taking the same
award yeah when there's people
women who've been women their whole
lives and done things that's just how
good men are i'm sorry no i'm not even
i'm not talking about the athletics i'm
talking about the women that you
are we'll be at my father
to answer your questions